very good morning to you emma radekanu
has made history in new york the 18 year
old from kent had to come through
qualifying just to take part in the u.s
open and then she won it without
dropping a single set at her moment of
victory she threw herself to the floor
in disbelief that was before saluting
her canadian opponent leila fernandez as
a great competitor the queen and the
prime minister have praised her
sensational performance but perhaps the
most appropriate tribute came from the
spice girls that's girl power right
there congrat now emma's friends and
supporters gathered to watch the match
at her club in beckenham and iva bennett
joined them for all of the celebrations
it was an emotional night in bromley
and this was only the first set
and now it's time for our champion
park langley tennis club is where it all
began for emma adukanu no wonder then
they're toasting her success
i had massive belief in her um i've
always said that she was if anyone i
coached up until this point you know and
would come through it would be it would
be emma
there's no disrespect to anybody else
but she's just always been tough on call
she's as hard as nails and now she's a
grand slam champion i mean it's just
absolutely unbelievable
nails were chewed
nerves were frayed
even the odd prayer was said
but throughout it all it seems there was
never any doubt
a champagne would indeed be flown
and when match point number three came
around it was almost as if she'd heard
their chance
there is going to be some party in here
tonight and the celebrations will not
stop here because this is a victory not
just for emma radokanu her family and
her friends but for the whole of british
tennis
that's because several bedtimes will
have been passed last night across the
country in the name of inspiring the
next generation i think it's amazing
it's very inspirational to just see her
come to that like that
just seeing her win a grand slam i think
it's just amazing i mean this is fast
your bedtime isn't it
yeah
is that why you liked it or did you like
watching her win
a bit of both
yes my first qualifying match all the
way to the final
to follow in her footsteps will of
course mean hard work but according to
her old coach the secrets to have fun
too
[Applause]
we laughed and giggled all the way
through and
sometimes she'd bring her coloring book
so when she was resting we'd sit on the
floor and do some coloring because she
was still a little tired
we didn't like makeup push cars up hills
or anything like that
the late night doesn't mean a day off
today in fact far from it the courts
here will be in use all day as the hunt
for the next radukanu begins
iva bennett sky news in bronwyn
well in a moment we'll be speaking to
our sports correspondent tom palmento
but first aisha zahid is at the bromley
tennis center for us this morning aisha
that's got to be a tennis center that is
absolutely brimming with pride
absolutely they're all going to be
incredibly proud of emma here waiting
for her to come back home and bring that
trophy home with her as well it's where
it all began for her she picked up a
racket here aged five and regularly
trained here throughout her school years
her school's only around the corner so
she was here before school after
sometimes even during school hours to
fit a bit of extra training in they've
been watching all of her matches here
and last night the place was packed out
with people who personally knew her
coaches as well as members of the club
friends as well all watching her make
history uh she it's every tennis club's
dream i think for seeing one of their
players reach a professional level but i
don't think anyone quite saw this coming
only a few weeks ago she was ranked
338th
in the world ranking so it's remarkable
to see her become a grand
grand slam champion without uh dropping
any sets along the way and it's going to
inspire the next generation of tennis
players especially those members here at
this club i expect the courts will be
packed out later today
all right we'll be keeping an eye on
that won't we and let's bring in tom
parmenter now who is in
derbyshire for us tom extraordinary
match wasn't it last night just put this
into context for us and it's one of the
greatest sporting achievements of all
time it's got to be
yeah and you just don't do this you do
not go from being
ranked 150 in the world just a few weeks
ago to a grand slam winner but that is
precisely what emma has done
and
it is just something that was a joy for
those watching last night or inspiring
tennis scintillating moments but we've
seen many plucky british underdogs over
the years haven't we who have put
british tennis fans through the mill
well this was nothing of the sword it
felt like you were watching one of the
great rivalries of sport and established
head-to-head with leyla fernandez but
both of them new names producing a next
um fascinating uh decade ahead with
those two and others coming into the mix
but emma radakani very much has that
next decade at her disposal and millions
of british tennis fans tuned in last
night because of course it was hastily
made free to wear during the course of
yesterday and what a decision that was
because
millions of people spent their saturday
night just loving the tennis the drama
the clinical nature of just how emma
radhikane makes her shots and finds the
very corners of that court it was an
extraordinary performance from an 18
year old who at the start of the year
was just wondering like pretty much
every other british teenager whether her
exams would be taking place but she
didn't drop a set through 10 games at
the u.s open the first qualifier to win
a major
grand slam title and she is of course
enjoying the moment trying to take it
all in
enjoying the adulation the prize money
that comes with it but she can do all
sorts of things inside and outside
tennis now given that victory last night
and we've seen of course through this
year so many teenage breakout sports
stories new faces coming to the fore but
i think what emma radicano did in new
york last night just about tops them all
well doesn't it just all right tom thank
you
now we'll show you martha kellner's
interview with the lady herself emma
radicanu in full at half past seven
now in other news the government is to
repeal many of the special powers that
it took to restrict people's freedom
during lockdown the prime minister is
expected to make a statement this week
on the government's plan for managing
covid in the autumn and the winter or
boris johnson will say that vaccines
will continue to be the first line of
defense in the fight against the virus
the independent joint committee on
vaccinations and immunisation is
expected to offer guidance this week on
who will receive booster jabs some as
early as this month
and powers that the government took to
impose restrictions on events close or
restrict access to schools and detain
people who are infectious will be
repealed
well we can speak more about some of
those plans with the deputy chief
executive of nhs providers safran cordy
good morning to you
i want to start by talking to you about
the situation uh with with case numbers
but particularly
hospitalizations um
if daily admissions keep on at this rate
i've read one estimate that has said
that the nhs would become overwhelmed by
november is is that right
i think what we are seeing now is a
steady rise in cases it's different to
the last
waves of covid that we have seen um
because we have got the interaction
between the vaccine and the number of
hospitalizations so the vaccine is
certainly effective in reducing
the number of hospitalizations and
reducing
severe
and death but we have to remember that
case numbers are going up and the
numbers of people in hospitals and
requiring ventilators is also going up
and the important thing to remember here
is that what it does is mean that
hospitals then have to focus
almost exclusively on treating covid
patients rather than dealing with that
big backlog of care that we've got which
has arisen
before the pandemic but also during the
pandemic
and if hospitalizations do continue at
the rate that we've been seeing at what
point um does the nhs run out of
capacity
i think it's impossible to tell that at
the moment i think you know we saw last
winter didn't we the the nhs under
incredible huge strain i think it's fair
to say that the nhs keeps going no
matter what and you know the very
welcome injection of funding last week
for the nhs will give it a real boost in
terms of
building capacity to help um us over
these winter months and beyond but
it it's fair to say that we have to keep
all of this in balance between
trying to tackle the backlog and also
think about how to treat people with
covid and so
preventing transmission is absolutely
key here
it's also worth saying though that we
are already seeing up and down the
country
um hospital trusts who are already
cancelling routine operations so the
very thing we are needing to focus on
which is getting that backlog down they
are already having to cancel operations
because of the number of kovid patients
in hospital but
it's impossible to answer your question
at the moment i think it really depends
how it pans out
i've been reading
some reports that suggest that the flu
season could be worse perhaps this
winter because people haven't been
mixing as much and therefore it it could
just be more more virulent
how prepared is the nhs
for the winter and if you could uh
answer that with particular reference to
staff shortages that you've been seeing
yeah so we you know
the nhs anticipates winter every year
it's one of the core elements of of
understanding demand and flow of
patients so so the nhs is preparing
itself
for winter and the additional pressures
that will come with that as you talked
about flu immunity is particularly low
this year because of all of the
protective measures we've put in place
for covid there's also rsv which is a
particularly virulent strain of
respiratory illness that affects
children which we are seeing emerging so
that is challenging
and alongside that we have got staffing
pressures we've got a workforce that is
incredibly tired i can't stress this
enough they've been going full pelt for
the last 18 months and and we have to
remember that whatever goes on in the
community so rising covid cases even
with a workforce that has been double
vaccinated they are still susceptible to
to covet just perhaps not as
but that means that they do need to then
isolate or they are too unwell to work
so we are in a situation where the
workforce is challenged and we will have
um difficulties staffing over winter you
know that is one of the challenges we
have every year and there's no reason to
think that that's going to go away and
will probably be even more challenging
and with the funding um package which
has been
announced um how far does that take you
in being able to address the backlog and
we've heard the horror stories that you
know that that waiting list could go up
to 13 million without the extra funding
how far does it take you
yeah well the secretary of state himself
said um could go up to 13 million i
think
the first thing to say is we you know
from the nhs perspective it's an
incredibly welcome injection of cash but
it is just a start and we need to really
look at
um
how that will pan out with kovit because
it's this interaction as i keep saying
between
covet cases
and getting through the backlog of care
so if covert cases rise if there is a
new variant of covid we're living with
the delta variant which is particularly
transmissible we could get a new variant
it's perfectly possible and
if that
has different characteristics or
different facets it means that
we need to focus on treating
covid patients alongside the backlog of
care i think it's going to take us until
at least the end of this parliament so
over the next three years to start to
make some real inroads but that
injection of support financial support
for the nhs and also for social care is
incredibly welcome but it is the start
rather than the end of the story and
that's what we have to remember
okay well good to talk to you this
morning safran cordray thank you
well the health secretary sergey javid
will be joining my colleague trevor
phillips this morning from half past
eight on trevor phillips on sunday
now leading trainers across the country
are opening their stable doors to the
public for the first time ever in
celebration of national racehorse week
the initiative is intended to help the
industry recover from covid and the
scandal caused by a trainer who was
pictured sitting on a dead horse well
that shocking image is included i should
say in ender brady's report
this is british horse racing at its
absolute best
thoroughbreds on the gallops in
gloucestershire with the men and women
who care for them 24 7.
the idea for a national week to
celebrate the racehorse is the
brainchild of trainer richard phillips
the typical life of racehorse is one
that should be you know copied by human
beings in many respects you know they
have a a great healthy life they have a
healthy diet they have
you know medical care to die for 24-hour
care you know and all these basic
messages should be good good across the
public because very funny racing is a
great industry and so many good people
look after so many good horses and it's
a celebration of the resource really
it's a scene that is repeated every
morning in every county in the country
racing was hit hard by the pandemic then
there was the damage done by this image
of irish trainer gordon elliott
he returns next week after serving a
six-month suspension for sitting on a
dead racehorse
across england scotland and wales 140
trainers will open their stables to the
public so they can visit and see for
themselves how well the horses are cared
for i just love everything the
animals give to us as human beings you
know they're very special animals what i
get from horses i think a lot of people
get from dogs and just standard pets at
home i think they're
amazing animals they're
just machines really i mean they're
they're so powerful there's they've got
so much personality and every racehorse
is different you know and what i love is
that every racehorse is loved by
somebody
grace muir founded the heroes charity
near wantage in oxfordshire 15 years ago
to re-home and retrain race horses she
gives them a second career and offers
young people from all backgrounds the
chance to work with them
i saw there was a use for these horses
after the racing days are over in those
days which probably is about 30 years
ago there wasn't so many to deal with
let's put it that way but i came up with
this idea of retraining them to do
another job because the breed is so
versatile and the horses are so
intelligent and so quick to learn
another skill
the original plan was to have national
racehorse day but it was so well
received by the public a day has been
extended to a week
so the hope is that national racehorse
week becomes an annual fixture in the
calendar to showcase everything that is
good about british horse racing
the sport and the industry has much to
be proud of those who work in it feel a
celebration of the race horse is long
overdue ended brady sky news in
gloucestershire
now the covid pandemic has exposed the
difference in quality of health care
that's experienced by different parts of
society and now a new project aims to
document the experience of some of those
providing care the black front line is
the largest oral history project
featuring black nurses and doctors from
around the world with 300 stories being
captured well i'm joined now by esther
armar who's executive director of the
amar institute of emotional justice and
also the founder of the black frontline
project good to see you this morning
esther thank you for coming on sky news
i know that you're bringing together
black frontline workers to share stories
and to raise awareness what are some of
the common themes that you're seeking to
illuminate
good morning thank you so much for
having me uh yes so the black front line
is a a project co-directed by myself uh
esther alma and dr kim galen of colby
black and we're currently gathering 100
stories from the uk from black doctors
and nurses it is powerful
devastating illuminating
and deeply sobering to listen to black
nurses and black doctors talk about
their fear
um the challenges they faced
the unrelet the relentless
um sorry the unrelenting loss
from seeing people die um feeling both
terrified by what they confronted by the
unknown but then also the amazing
communal coming together focusing in
head down um just trying to do the very
best they can with the tools that they
had to get through the backdrop of that
of course is the long-standing inequity
the institutional uh racism that exists
and how that impacts shapes and
determines so much of what is happening
and so um this project is about saying
their stories need to be centered in
order to explore how we strategize to
make structural change in healthcare in
the uk the stories are also from
the across the u.s and in ghana in west
africa yeah so it's a big undertaking
and they've been various inquiries as
well haven't there into the
disproportionate impact on on people of
color particularly those
on the front line because of covid what
have they told us of anything
so our project focuses specifically on
um black doctors and nurses
and what they're sharing with us is
the on the one hand the power of
community to um engage and stand
together but on the other hand the
isolation that comes from the kind of
long-standing inequities that puts them
on the front line without the kind of
protection and i don't just mean ppe but
the kinds of structural protections that
um
healthcare should offer all of us and so
this project my um which is globally led
we have a wonderful team in the uk a
team in the us and a team here in ghana
who will gathering the stories and um
part of the focus and the work and the
aim is for us storytelling is our
strategy to make structural change and
what we saw was an opportunity by
gathering these stories of having black
nurses and black doctors be not just on
the front line in terms of endangering
their lives but in making the kind of
change for the future health care that
we all deserve that their voices should
be centered in that and that's part of
this what project does it's a multi-year
project this is year one gathering those
stories that will be available available
publicly different from other oral
histories it will be publicly available
anywhere in the world on our the black
frontline website and i'll also be doing
events panels discussions and then doing
curricula the curricula is all about
shaping the healthcare of the future and
really looking and saying that black
nurses and black doctors deserve better
structural racism is a cancer that
actually kills all of us and it needs
not just to be eliminated individually
which is too often how it's defined but
for there to be the structural change so
that healthcare is a lifeline and
doesn't become a death sentence for
anybody because of inequity or racism
yeah you're building up a huge body of
evidence there um are you able to see
already
any specific changes that you think
could be easily implemented to help
one one really important one and i think
it's a long standing issue that actually
been highlighted again and again and
again is how
having so many black
nurses and doctors
uh right on the front line and too few
in places of power and leadership means
that you do not have a representation of
the experience the lived experience of
what it means to confront prejudice to
confront bigotry you don't have that
lived experience in leadership spaces
transforming
the experience across the board too
often the way that we come to racism is
we imagine and we think that it's about
black people that should be solved by
black people and it's their issue and
actually it is a societal issue and so
what black nurses and black doctors are
starting to share because all of the 300
doctors and nurses get asked the same
eight questions intentionally so we can
do comparative analysis and that it's
oral so we want to hear all the accents
the beauty what i call the sonic
blackness of all these doctors and
nurses on the front line and so what
they're sharing is that they are
offering their ideas for what change
looks like and then the work is to
institutionalize those so it no longer
is isolated voices calling for
individual change but this body of work
galvanizing organizing strategizing to
say that that there can't be a back to
pre-culvert reality the future has to be
changed and determined by those who've
been on the front line who've literally
faced covet eye to eye and still
delivered top quality healthcare we know
they deserve better but it can't be
platitudes and just talk it's got to
manifest in making the structural change
that would make their
jobs safer and their lives better and
those of their families and therefore
all of society all across the uk we're
actually still gathering the
stories of black doctors and nurses
right now so if you're somebody who's
watching and would like to contribute or
would like to um participate you can
absolutely um do that you can just go to
social media you can dm us on twitter at
the black front line just take out the a
of the c or you can email us the black
front line gmail gmail.com either one
it'll be absolutely fascinating to see
what comes out of that really good to
talk to you this morning esther thank
you thank you thank you so much for
having me
well it's coming up quarter to eight and
we're going to have a look at this
morning's papers with the broadcaster
ann diamond and the editor of the sunday
express michael booker stay with us
michael booker i want to introduce him
to you because he's the editor
responsible for the truly dreadful puns
on the front page of the daily express
but it is the biggest story in town
isn't it absolutely immense michael well
yes you two may be internationally known
uh tv journalists uh
and celebrities whereas i have made up a
word today which will be in the
dictionary next year mark my words but
yeah nice i think i got a little bit
excited last night and we all did i
think watching emma radicanu uh in the
us open and uh you know it's a fantastic
picture of her at the moment she
realized what she'd done at just 18
years old and it was a fantastic final
uh watching it against
fernandez and as you said in in the last
hour they look as though they will have
some rivalry going forward because you
know there was some pictures knocking
around yesterday of them a few years ago
at wimbledon
uh knocking up and here they are uh now
uh big celebrities big sports stars and
uh you can see with leila actually she
had a look in her eye i'm going to get
you back
uh so yeah it's it's all good uh they're
both really fantastic sporting stars and
uh the the country got behind her the
queen hailed it last night straight away
boris johnson the duchess of cambridge
everyone got caught up with it and you
can see the newspapers did as well
yeah i mean you're talking there about
those classic rivalries we might see
going on over the years the other the
lovely thing about it anne as well is
that everybody got behind emma didn't
they but we shouldn't forget her
opponent was tremendous
she was and only
barely a year older than emma herself no
she's one to watch as well and as as
mick says there i i reckon the rat that
rivalry will play out maybe in many more
finals and we're just going to have to
buy mick a book of words that begin with
m like empower uh you know an emotional
um there's lots of
words that begin with m uh for to suit
every occasion and we're gonna need it
in the next few years i reckon yeah i
think she's giving you a bit of shade
there about your uh wordsmithing mick
but we'll uh we'll move on uh front page
of the sunday telegraph uh talking about
an internal government report on an
impact assessment report essentially on
boris johnson's national insurance hike
yeah it's uh bad news really for boris
johnson if he he was hoping to get his
tory mps who had been
rumbling and grumbling last week about
the uh social care hike uh on uh
national insurance because the the this
inland revenue report
that has gone into the treasury this was
available uh around last week but the
mps didn't see it before they voted on
it and what it's saying is that this
hike will hit they're just about
managing now that's the the part of uh
the country where we heard i think of
them under theresa may's government
those people who at the end of each week
each month they've got
they've paid their bills and they
haven't got much left uh to spend on any
luxuries or or anything else for that
matter and it says that they've this
report is saying that it will have a
harmful effect on people in those sort
of families uh and it will affect uh
they could affect family breakdowns as
well it could also affect wealth
creation and stop businesses decided to
invest as well as part of this report so
it's a gloomy reading for the prime
minister gloomy reading for those red
wall mps as well who
they said they've been taking the
temperature
of their constituency and they say that
there's there's a rebellion growing
there amongst voters who after all have
only lent their vote to the tories at
the moment to see if they can be trusted
and in one focus group they did say it
was the poll tax 2.0
that's not just a headline come up from
with the telegraph that's actual voters
saying it and
we know what that did for margaret
thatcher don't we
well exactly and if you look at the
leader in the telegraph today it's just
one big long leader saying that they
have their tories have to scrap this
plan entirely yeah all right well let's
um go through a bit of a gear change
here and we want to talk about uh a new
trend for bridal bouquets
yes if you are a bride-to-be um you can
go green by actually going brown and
yeah i'm not i'm not sure this is going
to catch on
basically
yes it's your bouquet basically we're
coming into autumn and shane connolly
who's done lots of royal weddings um
says that engaged couples are favoring
in-season alternatives over brightly
colored imported um
flowers and everything so he's saying
that you know even twigs
even twigs and brown leaves can make a
very attractive bouquet
well i suppose
you're an autumnal bride i suppose it
sort of it goes it goes with the flow
doesn't it a little bit i had a look i
had a google to see whether it was
actually a thing and you can see a huge
variety of bouquets with browns and and
oranges so yeah it is it is a thing
apparently another thing that's a thing
uh michael apparently is 12 000 pound
sofas for dogs
what a time to be alive hey
well yeah when i when i owned a dog a
few years ago you can sometimes be
caught by madness and start buying them
all sorts of expensive rubbish now i
think i would have stopped at this this
is the twelve thousand pound uh settee
that's been designed by christopher howe
now this pictured in the mail there now
those dogs are sat on it they have no
idea that that is a luxurious couch so
they just sit like that looking like
dogs do uh
dozily into the middle distance
wondering what the heck is going on they
would you could stick them on a on a
poof and then be happy that's what they
do they just rub themselves on things
and that's what dog you don't want a
twelve thousand pounds so foreign
smells everywhere you don't want that on
a twelve thousand pound sofa do you just
give them a rug and they'll be happy to
chew it well let's bring you in here and
i can see you wanna jump in there i also
wanna point out the insightful analysis
from an expert that says dogs don't
really care what they sit on as long as
it's comfortable and ideally has sides
dogs don't but you do because if you
value your dog and their place in your
living room then you want their chair to
look nice don't you it needs to be part
of your whole thing i've actually found
myself looking at a chaise long for my
little dog at a cost of only just under
a thousand so i can understand somebody
with far too much money and maybe a lot
of taste going as far as 12 grams there
you go there you go thank you very much
both of you it's been great having you
on the program